what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so by my estimation we have about
two weeks before thor ragnarok comes out
which I firmly believe is going to be
one of the most anticipated movies of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe outside of
infinity war and black panther just
because we've yet to see a black panther
film yet so you know having that come
out in February is gonna be a pretty
stellar but you know for me I think Thor
Ragnarok I'm gonna be honest with you
guys I think that Odin's gonna die
I think Thor's gonna inherit the
odinforce and I think Marvel is gonna
use that as a way to basically explain
why it is that Thor is able to last as
long as he is against Thanos and
infinity war so what I want to do for
the next couple weeks is I want to run
over the character some of the more
prominent characters that are going to
appear in in Thor Ragnarok a lot of the
characters that we haven't seen and so
in this video we are gonna focus on the
character of Surtur now for those of you
guys who saw my origin story video on
Surtur bear with me because some of that
stuff might seem pretty familiar to you
so I do not consider myself to be an
expert in real-world Norse mythology but
to the best of my knowledge
Serdar as he exists in Marvel Comics is
a little bit different than the way that
he exists in in Norse mythology and
Norse mythology of the real world
Serdar is basically a yotan and as I
understand it what that means is he's
not really a man but he's not really a
god and he effectively is part of the
coming of Ragnarok which means that when
the process of the destruction of Asgard
begins to take place he'll be one of the
forerunners that leads to the Ragnarok
event happening but the way in which it
works so again you know as far as I
understand the way in which it works in
real world Norse mythology is that
Serdar will not actually be the one to
kill Odin instead Serdar would be the
one to battle someone named Freya now in
Norse mythology again as I understand it
you basically have two types of gods you
have what are called the icier gods I
think is how it's pronounced and then
you have the Vanier gods which are
basically just two separate sexes of
gods within the Norse mythological
pantheon the icier gods are the most
popular ones they are you know Odin Thor
hella Loki the Vanier gods are like
Freyr which is Freya's twin brother they
got a fertility you've got like na nan I
think it is or Nana I'm not really sure
exactly how you pronounce that but it's
essentially kind of split into two
different parts in Marvel Comics they
don't take that approach in terms of the
Marvel Comics publications
Serdar didn't actually make his
appearance and
until journey into mystery issue number
97 with Serdar making his appearance
alongside others details of asgard line
was designed to provide this sort of
chronology which is to say how it was
Odin rose to power what Odin was doing
while he was in power a lot of that
stuff predated the arrival of Thor and
so it focused almost exclusively on the
early days of Asgard itself from the
time that it was first created about to
the time that Odin took power and the
following days when it came to Surtur
while his first appearance in issue
number 97 of journey into mystery was a
cameo feature because tales of Asgard
was a backup feature he had basically
shown up in his full form and received
his full origin in issue number 99 and
again what the whole basis of that story
basically told us was that Surtur is
essentially a fire demon meaning he's
one of the oldest beings in existence
and actually predates Odin by quite some
time and because Odin was the leader of
Asgard and while real world Norse
mythology had at Surtur fighting against
Freya in Ragnarok what Jack Kirby and
Stanley had to do was effectively
rectify and really just kind of
consolidate those two concepts together
in a way that made sense and so what
they ended up doing was they basically
crafted this backstory where they
established that somewhere along the
line Odin and his brothers viele and V
had faced off against Serdar in defiance
and as a result of that sort harboured
this sort of animosity towards Odin that
lasted for quite some time now reveal
E&V died during the conflict with Odin
and this ultimately resulted in him
creating the odinforce when he absorbed
their life energies fast-tracking to
this second encounter between Odin and
Surtur when the two of them battled Odin
confined Serdar to the core of the earth
and so not only had he previously been
defied by Odin and their second
encounter
he'd been defeated and then locked away
and imprisoned in the earth itself and
so what this ended up doing was allowing
Stan Lee and Jack Kirby to effectively
go forward and establish Serdar as this
arch-nemesis of Odin himself in the
Marvel Norse mythological pantheon now
what this does is this moves directly
into the events of journey and a mystery
issue number 104 again written by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby which is the first
time in Marvel Comics that the concept
of Ragnarok is established and what this
does is it basically says that there
will come a time whereby Loki will
essentially free Surtur and when that
happens that will set in motion the
different stages that will result in the
coming
ragnarok itself now as an aside here on
the whole when it came to their method
of storytelling Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
were relatively consistent with
continuity and because Jack Kirby was
such a huge fan of Norse mythology he
would constantly chime in with Stan Lee
and say actually that's not the way that
it's supposed to go and so the idea of
Ragnarok as it was originally presented
by Kirby himself to Stan Lee in terms of
how the story was written and carried on
so on and so forth
the idea was that the prophecy would
basically say that there would be this
massive winner that would spread all
throughout Asgard and then Heimdall
would basically sound the trumpet
indicating the invasion of Loki Loki and
Thor would battle one another and in
their battle would be interrupted by the
Midgard serpent effectively this giant
dragon that would rise from the earth
and then Thor would defeat the dragon
but then Asgard itself would be totally
obliterated following that the concept
of Surtur being the being who sits at
the very end of all things waiting for
Ragnarok to happen and for his
opportunity to attack Asgard would take
that opportunity to show up and then
just totally incinerate whatever was
left of Asgard itself and that would be
the process of Ragnarok now there's no
indication in the original stories
written by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby that
Surtur would basically be the person who
would kill Odin instead it basically
just meant that Asgard would just be
totally incinerated and all the gods
would die and this was important because
what this did is it allowed Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby to go forward into the Thor
pantheon always teased in the concept
that Ragnarok was just over the horizon
is the next story arc the story arc
where Thor dies and so it would be a
really cool concept in terms of how it
unfolded and it allowed things to
progress pretty steadily in terms of the
Thor landscape now one thing to keep in
mind is that because journey in a
mystery was originally an anthology
series that largely featured Thor
because he was the standout star
eventually journey into mystery
effectively went away and was replaced
by the Thor line of comics and that's
the reason why you can go through the
Thor numbering and you have journey in a
mystery issue number 125 and then Thor
issue number 126 it's a continuation of
the numbering but the titles name
changes now because Serdar would be the
force by which Ragnarok would
effectively occur or at the very least
he was one of the most notable enemies
of Odin and Thor between May of 1966 and
really October of 1975 Surtur only
appeared a handful of times in that he
appeared in issues
76 177 200 and 240 and for the most part
the concept of Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
continued on in the way that it always
had in the sense that Serdar would be an
indication of the coming of Ragnarok
that Serdar was a major force against
Odin and Thor and he would basically
just escape his imprisonment he would
face off against the Asgardians he would
be defeated and he would be imprisoned
again but because of the fact that Thor
was continuing to rise in popularity and
some of Marvel's most popular titles at
the time included Doctor Strange The
Avengers
things like that we would end up seeing
the Thor stories involve a lot of these
characters the other half is that
because this concept was popular Marvel
would also use it for the purpose of
bolstering characters who were not that
popular at the time but throw them into
the story so that they would gain
traction or at least Marvel hoped they
would gain traction among readers which
was the case with a character of Black
Knight but in June of 1977 running all
the way up between Thor issues 260 to
270 one writer Len Wein had taken over
the title and while in wine was not the
most iconic rider of the Thor mythos the
person who was drawing for the Thor
title at the time certainly was and that
was Walt Simonson now Walt Simonson drew
you know issues 262 to 71 in addition to
Thor annual number seven but with issue
number 337 he officially took over the
title riding Thor for about four years
between November of 1983 - I think it
was June of 1987 Walt Simonson was for
the Thor mythos what Chris Claremont was
for the x-men in the sense that Chris
Claremont came along he began writing
the x-men and basically transformed it
into more of a soap opera based comic
that focused largely on character
development as opposed to just you know
petty squabbles and conflicts Walt
Simonson while writing and drawing Thor
expanded the mythos by leaps and bounds
in quite a few ways for example one of
the things that he did with issue number
337 really his inaugural issue and
taking the title over was to introduce
someone named beta ray bill the first
person to ever lift the hammer of Thor
this was a kind of mythos that Walt
Simonson had added to the you know
entire line of Thor but for Serdar
himself Walt Simonson actually took what
it was that Jack Kirby and Stan Lee had
done and bolstered it in a way that
hadn't really been seen before and the
reason why I say that is because between
issues number 337
and 353 Walt Simonson began writing a
story which is largely referred to as
the Serdar saga and what this does is it
basically took the concept of Ragnarok
as it had been established by Lee and
Kirby and said it's finally happening
it's finally taking place now this story
was told in a couple different ways
really in stages the first was the idea
that Sardar was building something
called the twilight blade that if it was
lit a flame using the eternal flame that
would basically make him unstoppable and
it would allow him to storm up really
the entirety of Asgard destroy a scart
proper and internists sites to the
universe and obliterate all things in
existence now the eternal flame itself
was basically this flame that was
guarded by Vice Surtur himself and was
stolen by Odin and villian V which led
to their encounter with Sirte in the
first place in terms of the Serdar saga
what this did is it basically began the
process of setting in motion the stages
of Ragnarok in the sense that one of the
first people recruited by Serdar was
Malekith the accursed basically one of
the Dark Elves who was hell-bent on just
doing bad things cuz that's what he does
but it was essentially this coming
together of all these enemies of Asgard
proper now Malekith was tasked with
capturing something called the casket of
ancient winters and the casket of
ancient winters is essentially this
artifact that contains the infinite cold
of nifflheim of the land of the frost
giants and the idea is that if the
casket is open it'll basically unleash
this infinite cold wherever it's at and
wherever it can in gain access to the
way in which this happened was by not
only Malekith unleashing it on earth but
when the Bifrost was opened by Serdar
the infinite cold spread through the bry
frost and directly into Asgard itself
and so this led to this massive storming
of Asgard were like Heimdall fell and
all these things ended up happening
and so following this what we ended up
having was Serdar basically storming
Asgard intending to capture the eternal
flame due to the fact that he had also
been allied alongside Loki only for us
to find out that Loki was a double agent
that he had pretended to be an ally of
Surtur only to turn against him at the
last minute when Serdar had gone to
capture the eternal flame and then
discovered it was an illusion created by
Loki and so what this ended up doing is
it resulted in Loki Thor and Odin coming
together and facing off against Serdar
resulting in sorters defeat and his
imprisonment and something called the
eternal Twilight I think it is a
dimension whereby anybody whose confined
in that location is effectively locked
there forever they'll never be able to
come back and he was essentially Walt
Simonson's way of crafting this massive
epic insane Ragnarok almost happened but
now it's okay everything sorted out
Surtur's been defeated loki learned his
lesson everything's cool the reason why
this matters is because with this story
being written in 1986 and 1987 Walt
Simonson had actually left the Thor line
to launch x-factor and so following his
departure from the Thor title for the
most part certain wasn't really seeing
that much he was seen a couple of times
when Tom DeFalco was writing the stories
but that was about it I mean there
really wasn't much with regards to the
sort of character because most writers
looked at the run of Walt Simonson and
saw it is almost impossible to follow up
on the other half of this was that
Marvel was experiencing a lot of waxes
and wanes when it came to like the
mid-1990s you had the comic bust you had
a lot of things taking place and so
because of the fact that comics sales
were at an all-time low
Marvel was facing bankruptcy what they
had to do was actually look at what
titles were selling and which titles
weren't and find a way to either
consolidate or cancel and so what they
did is they launched a story called
heroes reborn and this came out of like
the onslaught saga and the idea was that
this being onslaught who was basically
the combined minds of I guess that
combined emotional states of magneto and
Charles Xavier brought together it
resulted in like Thor in the Fantastic
Four and essentially the characters who
weren't selling diving directly into one
slot in an effort to destroy the entity
which in turn led to them being
recreated and resurrected by Franklin
Richards the son of Reed Richards in
this little blue sphere but the idea of
heroes reborn was to essentially sort of
soft reboot a lot of the characters who
just weren't doing well ultimately all
the heroes who were in the heroes
born universe came back during the story
heroes return and the Thor title was
taken over by a guy named Dan Jergens
now Dan Jurgen started writing Thor from
1998 up until about 2004 2005 2006
because what this was designed to do was
basically revamp the Thor mythos now a
lot of this came out of the fact that
Marvel had escaped bankruptcy by the
skin of their teeth but editor-in-chief
Joe Quesada had stepped in and said we
got way too out of hand in like the
1980s and 1990s we have to consolidate
we have to focus on a core set of titles
and so what they ended up doing was they
basically tasked Dan Jergens with the
process of going through and setting the
stage for the actual Ragnarok which is
to say the actual destruction of Asgard
and so what this did is it led to a
series of stories that culminated in the
death of Odin in a battle against Surtur
and so what ended up happening is that
with Odin dead and Surtur having
defeated him this launched the actual
Ragnarok story and for the most part
Serdar was just one part of the
landscape of Ragnarok and so the result
is that you know it led to things like
Thor becoming rune King Thor basically
God going through all the processes of
Odin you know things along those lines
but it was interesting in and of itself
in terms of how all that began to unfold
but ultimately we ended up learning that
Ragnarok was this endless cycle that all
the gods were destined to die and be
reborn which is exactly what happened I
mean following the events of Ragnarok
writer J michael Straczynski took over
the thor title and he began crafting
things like the return of the Asgardians
in the sense that loki was resurrected
in the body in a body that was meant for
sift that Heimdall for example was
resurrected and you know all these
different things there were in their
mortal forms and they had to be
quote-unquote woken up but once they
were it was the process of rebuilding
Asgard and like Broxton Oklahoma
different things like that but for
Serdar question still lingered among
fans in terms of what actually happened
to him will he ever come back if the
cycle is endless then that means Sodor
can't ever really die because he'll
always be reborn alongside everybody
else the same question lingered with
regard to Odin and so what J michael
Straczynski did in Thor vol 3 issue 7 &
8 is he crafted a two-part story that
answered the questions about both Odin
and Serdar and essentially what he did
is he came along and he said the two of
them you know with Odin having died at
the hands of Surtur and with Surtur
having died when Thor quote-unquote
ended the cycle of Ragnarok is what it
did is it took their essences and
through them into this sword of Dark
Dimension this alternate reality where
they were just locked in an eternal
battle forever they would fight during
the day they would kill each other they
would be reborn the next day and the
cycle would just continue forever and
ever and ever and ever now because of
the fact that the stories at the time
focused on Thor
rebuilding Asgard and Straczynski did
not want to bring back Odin at the time
what it meant was that Odin was offered
the opportunity to finally destroy
Serdar and to return back to the mortal
plane and take up his rightful role as
ruler of Asgard but declined because if
that were the case there would always be
the opportunity for sir to come back but
if Serdar and Odin were locked in a
eternal battle with each other then they
would just stay there for all time there
would never be a chance for Serdar to
actually make his return and that's how
things continued on in Marvel Comics for
quite some time but all of this changed
with a story called fear itself now for
the most part fear itself didn't really
have much to do with cert or proper
instead fear itself actually focused on
someone called the serpent also known as
Kolbe or son who is basically this
brother of Odin that nobody ever knew
about and the whole basis of the story
was the idea that Kolbe or son was the
actual rightful heir to Asgard but that
Odin had effectively used SERP the
throne and locked his brother away so it
was this introduction of a character
that we'd never really seen before and
the story was really cool in and of
itself which we will cover but the whole
idea was that because Cole bore son was
basically this almost unstoppable
omnipotent force what ended up happening
is that at the time Marvel began
focusing on stories involving Loki by
himself in the relaunch tidal journey in
the mystery and so what Loki ended up
doing was basically traveling to this
dimension Worster during Odin were
locked together and then made a bargain
and said that he would free Surtur
if Serdar was willing to give Loki a
piece of the twilight blade which will
allow him to basically go through
rewrite the history of cold war son and
then in turn allow him to be defeated
and that's exactly what happened you
know Serdar was effectively freed and
went back to his own realm and so what
this did is it allowed Marvel to
essentially go forward and half Surtur
there in the background just kind of
waiting to be used that if Marvel chose
to bring him back they would be able to
the issue with this is that the box had
already been opened
Ragnarok had already been written that
story had already been done they really
couldn't do Ragnarok again for the most
part they tried when it
like Loki last days in the collapse of
the multiverse but in terms of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I don't think
we're actually going to see Serdar as a
major force which is to say the main guy
behind it all we know that basically
hella is the one who seems to be
instigating the events of Ragnarok the
daughter of low-key but Serdar seems to
be just one of a number of forces who
were there and it may simply just be
that he follows in line with a
traditional role of Ragnarok in the
sense that once Ragnarok is over once
hella basically leads to the destruction
of Asgard that sorter will then emerge
but the fact remains that I think that
ultimately it may end up being that like
Serdar is basically the one responsible
for the death of Odin that you have Thor
and you have the Incredible Hulk who
step up they try to fight Serdar they
both get defeated only steps up and the
two of them fight one another and they
both die and this sets the stage for
Thor inheriting the odinforce going
forward into an affinity war that's my
prediction in terms of Weiss orders in
that movie you know why we end up seeing
him there it'll be cool because
surgery's like a thousand feet tall I
mean he's massive in size so it'll be
cool to see sort of facing off against
Hulk and you know well it'll be cool to
see him see him involved but again I
don't think he's gonna be a main
character I think he'll just kind of be
a guy who shows up at the very end once
it's all said and done we'll probably
see him fight for like ten minutes 15
minutes and then that'll really be about
it but in any event guys hopefully this
helps to educate you all on the nature
of Surtur himself as a character
hopefully you're able to go forward into
thor ragnarok understanding what he's
about so you won't feel lost when people
are talking about him but with that
being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explain and make
sure you guys for the sub button to
become part of the Rob quark if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]